y
haga él cada día su rostro le recuerda
el 13 de noviembre de 2015 día en que
recibió un disparo en la cara y el brazo
en el bataclán pero de esta herida sacó
su fuerza
[Música]
tengo suerte de seguir viva siempre lo
he puesto en perspectiva podría haber
muerto llevaré las marcas del resto de
mi vida incluyendo en la cara y el brazo
pero sigo adelante las cosas serán
diferentes pero sigo aquí eso no tiene
precio
[Música]
esa noche 130 personas en todo parís
fueron asesinadas por el mismo grupo de
terroristas yihadistas
muchas más resultaron heridas
acá él llegó tarde al bataclán con su
pareja apenas unos minutos antes que los
terroristas
[Música]
los yihadistas abrieron fuego y gael se
desplomó en el suelo herida por los
disparos de kalashnikov
[Música]
cuando abrí los ojos un terrorista
estaba de pie sobre mí entonces me di
cuenta del estado de mi brazo que estaba
destrozado y de que había perdido la
mitad de mi cara mi mano podría
atravesarla podía sentir el interior de
mi cara me estaba tragando los dientes
pero no podía hacer ningún ruido porque
necesitaba que pensaran que ya estaba
muerto
y
su compañero y hacía a su lado herido de
muerte
espero dos horas y media por ayuda
aferrándose a la vida
y el famoso túnel oscuro en el que tu
vida pasa frente a tus ojos
alucinaciones todos mis seres queridos
uno tras otro me hablaban especialmente
mi hijo que me dijo mamá tienes que
aguantar sentí que él me sostenía y eso
me hizo permanecer viva y salir justo
antes de que el lugar fuera asaltado una
vez en el hospital para él se dio cuenta
de que tenía heridas similares a las de
los soldados de la primera guerra
mundial conocidos como caras rotas pero
no vio su rostro sino hasta varios días
después
[Música]
habían puesto una sábana quirúrgica
sobre el espejo del baño para que no
pudiera verme
decidí arrancarla entonces me di cuenta
de que había perdido una buena parte de
mi cara
este fue el segundo gran shock para mí
[Música]
un shock porque parte de su rostro había
sido arrancado por completo como lo
muestra esta imagen de su historia
médica
para reconstruirlo le quitaron un trozo
de hueso y músculo de la pierna
acá él ha pasado por 40 operaciones para
poder comer hablar y sonreír de nuevo
[Música]
gracias a esa cirugía se podido llevar
una vida normal tener un rostro que
asusta menos
tenemos que demostrarles a esos
terroristas que todo lo que hicieron fue
darnos más ganas de vida
[Música]
en la apertura del juicio de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre en el
banquillo hay 14 personas entre ellas
sal abdeslam el principal acusado y
único superviviente del comando
terrorista
de hudson
no sé si sala abdeslam se decidirá
hablar
él es quien más información tiene el
estado de ese día
simbólicamente es poderosos nos gustaría
que se explicará solo unas palabras
incluso una disculpa si lo hace podría
darnos a todos un poco de tranquilidad
por acá
gael es una de las 1760 demandantes en
este caso histórico aún no sabe si
declarará pero estará presente en el
tribunal con la esperanza de que se haga
justicia a todas las víctimas